Right.
Do you think that it's possible?
Do you ever entertain the idea that
it's possible that we are the only
intelligent life in the known universe?
I like,
I tend to restrict myself to the galaxy,
right?
So I do think it's possible that at the
moment there's one civilization in the
Milky Way and that's us. And I
think that's important. Actually.
It goes back to, I was saying
at the start about the, uh,
astronomy and cosmology being part of
the framework within which you have to
think if you're looking for meaning or
you're looking for how we should behave
even politically. You know, the,
that has a bearing to me, I mean,
imagine that we're the only place where
there is intelligence in this galaxy and
how should we behave,
right?
Should we actually not withstanding the
fact that we are tiny and fragile things
and insignificant physically,
should we consider ourselves extremely
valuable in that respect because there's
nowhere else where you,
you know,
that I would go as far as to say there
would be nowhere else where meaning
exists in the Milky Way.
Because meaning it's one of those things
that scientists don't talk about very
much. Although Richard Fineman, one
of my great heroes did talk about it.
There's a quote where he says,
what is the meaning of it all?
It's a great essay called the value of
science and so what is self evidently
true is that meaning exists here because
it means some things he was so that's
kind of an obvious statement.
Your life mean something to you
and me and so meaning exists,
but I think it is a local and
temporary phenomenon. I think it's,
it emerges meaning emerges
from configurations of atoms,
which is what we are. We are simply
that. We're nothing more than that.
We're very,
very rare configurations of atoms I
think and so that means that we are,
if you go all the way
down that line of logic,
we are the only island
meaning in the galaxy.
I meaning only to ourselves.
Yeah.
It means something to us because we're
the only ones who can grasp the concept
and we are finite.
We are finite organism.
We have this temporary existence while
we're here and to us there is meaning.
Yeah. And that's, I don't know
any other way to define it,
so I'll define it like that. I
don't think there's globe. Yeah.
Otherwise you have to believe there's
some kind of global meaning and that's a
god thing.
I don't think that's,
I think it's more wonderful and,
and more challenging to us because we
have to take responsibility for it to say
we should operate search that
we are it in this galaxy.
There's nothing else. I'm sure. I'm just,
I'm sure there are other civilizations
out there in the universe because are 2
trillion galaxies. I, I just can't believe
this hasn't happened in other places.
The question is how often does it then,
how widely spaced out of civilizations
and I think they're very widely spaced
and I think there may be one or
two per galaxy on the average.
I could put that as you said,
that what you said at Beazley that
what else can we think? Right.
Well and what else do you want?
I mean,
I think what it says is you have to take
responsibility for all those things or
spiritual things that you think about
and the emotional things you think about
it. You, you, you are, you
are responsible for that.
You are that for that,
whatever that is,
it exists in you and it will only
exist for short amount of time and so
well, you know, make the
best of it will be my beats.
So unbelievably compelling though to
consider the idea that somewhere out there
there's another civilization that may
be even more advanced than us and this,
this thought of it is just
so attractive. It's, it's,
it's incredible.
They're the shit there should be,
if,
if civilizations are common
or even slightly common,
then there should be civilizations ahead
of us because there's been so much time.
But wouldn't you want to see
what that's like? Yeah. I mean,
we've been a compelling,
you imagined the timescales we've
been around as a civilization,
let's say 40,000 years. I don't know how
long our civilization has been around.
Let's say that the,
the,
the galaxy is pretty much as old as the
university's 13 billion years worth of
time. So the idea that there are
no, no civilizations, arrows,
you know, a hundred million years ago, 200
million years ago, 1 billion years ago.
And imagine what they be like if
they'd survived. I mean, we've been,
we've been around,
we've had science for let's say Cindy
to neaten are Kapernick is 500 years at
most. We've had, and look
what we've done, we've,
we've gone beyond the solar system
with voyager. We've walked on the moon.
Um, we've, we're, we're about
to go to Mars, I would think.
So we're about to begin colonizing
our own solar system. Um,
so we've done that in 500 years.
So imagine a million years in the future.
So I would,
it's one of the arguments
often used to say,
there aren't any civilizations
out there in the galaxy.
It's called the Fermi paradox.
Because if you imagine a civilization
that's a million years ahead of us,
they should have written their
presence across the sky by now.
They should use to see them.
I mean,
you'll see us if we survive in million
years into the future. Actually,
even a few thousand years in the future,
we will be exploring the galaxy.
We will have spacecraft that are going
to have the stars. We will be doing it.
So our signature will become visible.
I'm sure if we last into the medium term,
would we choose to
not do that?
Here's my thought on that
is uncontacted tribes like,
do you know about the,
the gentleman who was the,
a missionary who visited
North Sentinel Island? Yeah.
It was killed by the natives
north central island,
which is a really unusual place because
they branched off from Africa 60,000
years ago and they've been living on this
one small ion, the size of Manhattan.
And as well as we know,
there's only about 39 of them left
somewhere around there. And um,
we can't, we're not supposed to contact
them like people were not supposed we,
we're supposed to like leave them alone.
And there are rare tribe when
they find them in the Amazon.
The uncontacted tribes are
initial instinct is back
off back when you leave them
alone. Leave them alone. Do you
think that perhaps the universe,
like if there is a civilization that's a
million times more advanced than us and
been around here for you know,
the millions of years of life
as opposed to quarter million,
why would they,
why would they let us know?
They look at us dropping bombs on
each other and polluting the ocean.
It's sucking all the fish out and putting
the clouds into the skies of dirt and
particles and why would they like look
at these crude monkeys. Look are there,
they don't,
they're so far beyond where they need to
be before they could join the galactic
civilization or whatever.
It is true.
It's an argument that the
reason argument as well,
the IT technology so advanced would
be difficult for us to detect.
I mean we tend to think of, you know,
when you say written across the sky,
I suppose it's true, I'm thinking of star
ships and things like star wars, right?
Big Energy.
Things that you can see the signature of,
but actually it may be that
the civilization just becomes
a nano civilization in
a tiny little,
none of it because that's more efficient.
It's a better way to do things.
So it's possible, I suppose,
that there are space
probes all over the place.
They're so small and it's
so efficient and you sell,
it'll energy that we just don't see him.
I suppose that is possible.